okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness is now out and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the ending explaining the cameos in
it and also giving our full review of
the film once more we are back with the
doctor who makes you forget rather than
being the doctor you forgot about the
film follows him as he goes toe-to-toe
with wonder in the marvel magic version
of civil war and we culminate with him
meeting a brand new character that
teases an upcoming threat come the end
of the film that's as far as i want to
get before we go spoiler heavy so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now there will be no memory spells
from this point on but please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for unforgettable breakdowns
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness okay so the movie
opens with defender strange attempting
to protect america chavez from a giant
demon that wants to steal her powers
trying to get to the book of ashanti
this seems like the only way to stop
whatever it is chasing after them in
case you don't know the book of ashanti
in the comics is described as being a
text comprised of pure light that has
the ability to counter its opposite the
darkhold wonder got her filthy little
black fingers on this during one
division and we learned throughout the
film that it slowly started corrupting
her overtime america has similar powers
to how she does in the comics except for
that she can't really control him here
which becomes a big character arc that
she goes on when feeling scared her
powers come into effect and she's able
to open up multiversal puddles that
appear like stars similar the source
material however she hasn't quite come
to grips with these yet and the movie
actually paints defender strange out as
quite a bad guy because he tries to kill
her in order to strip her powers early
on much in the same way that the mcu one
said he would happily sacrifice peter
and tony to protect the time stone this
guy literally says
them kids however the demon stabs him
and america manages to escape in the
main mcu universe along with defender
strange who dies just after freeing her
from its grasp in the film we learned
that america got scared once by a bee
and she opened a portal which sucked her
mothers through america believed that
this killed them however strange to say
that he thinks they're alive which is in
keeping with the comics at the sanctorum
our doc gets a flashy of this opening
scene but he thinks it was all a dream
now it turns out it's christine palmer's
wedding day who moved on in the five
years that strange was gone guess
everyone getting snapped had an effect
on the doctor because she had no
patience hey that was right anyway
strange pretends to be happy but he's
about as happy as happy hogan is this
month cause it's may
now at the wedding party new york is
attacked by gorganzos who's going to
strip chavez of her powers after
defeating the beast strange ends up
learning about america seeing the body
of defender and realizing that the
monster was brought in by witchcraft he
goes to the only person that he thinks
can help now wanda has had a tough old
time in the mcu as not only were her
parents killed in front of her she was
also experimented on watched her by the
died caused civil war had to kill a love
of her life and then watch him die after
thanos hit rewind then then right she
enslaved an entire town made vision and
some kids and then again had to watch
them die so i probably not in the best
of moods now we learn in the film that
dreams are actually us seeing through
the multiverse and these are our
variants wanda has one where she's with
her kids which lets her know that there
are universes out there in which she can
be with them she dreams of them every
night but her heart breaks in the
morning when they're taken away faster
than your plans of finally having a good
year or after the last two pieces of
[ __ ] strange arrives at her new home and
she brings up america by name without
stephen telling her so he realizes
something is wrong she very much refuses
to sacrifice the thing that she loves
which juxtaposes stephen who gave up
christine in order to save the universe
guy literally said
them cats now she reveals the darkhold
which stephen warns can get a dark hold
on people and it's clear she's corrupted
wanda gives him a chance to hand over
america peacefully like the war of
independence and he heads back to
comitage not sure if that's historically
accurate but arriving there wonder rolls
in like a bad thought and we're
introduced to rintro pulling from the
comics this minotaur's arc is pretty
much halfway through how he's introduced
in them and in the source material the
character was born on the
extra-dimensional planet of raval rindra
ended up repairing strange's cloak of
levitation which had been destroyed in a
battle and after handing it back he was
invited to become the sorceress
apprentice in the comics he lived at the
sanctum sanctuarium which is changed up
to comatogear now if you've been
following the channel you'll know he did
a plot league breakdown that was pretty
much 90 of what was in the movie however
this had some additional scenes that may
or may not have been in the original
film because of how accurate it was i do
think that this is what was originally
shot and according to it there was a
scene in which the mcu's motto arrived
to kill wander if you cast your mind
back to the end of doctor strange he was
hunting wizards but whether it's true or
not either way it's not in the film now
it was supposed to open the movie but i
kind of think it might have been cut so
we get more of a twist when it's
revealed that she's the villain after a
big battle strange in america escapes
through the multiverse and they arrive
in a utopian world and the pair travel
to the sanctum sanctorum along the way
they pass the first big cameo bruce
campbell who appears as someone selling
pizza balls in this world food is free
but he wants some money for it and
there's also a great reference to the
evil dead in which strange enchants his
hand this repeatedly tries to slap him
much like the one from the evil dead 2
which was also directed by sam raimi
bruce also appears in the second post
credit scene which is when it finally
stops and the guy can go back to pizza
balls which hey i gave you girl a piece
of these balls and some nuts what nuts
these nuts what
anyway after being captured by mordo
strange is taken before the illuminati
who in the comics were a super group
that secretly controlled things behind
the scenes first teased that on an app
on tony's phone in iron man 2 the lineup
is highly different here to what's come
before the movie isn't specifically
based on one graphic novel a comic book
run however it does pull from several
books like house of m and even age of
ultron in the latter we watched as the
world was taken over by the maniac
machine and wolverine traveled back in
time in order to kill hank pym when
returning to the present he found a
completely alien timeline to what he'd
known and there he met defender strange
and also a twisted iron man the pair of
which ended up interrogating him along
with professor rex who of course appears
in the film it was revealed that the
world had changed massively because hank
wasn't there for several of their major
battles which sort of reflects a big
plot point we'll get into in just a bit
in this universe the world now had a new
enemy morgan lafaye who in case you
don't know is a witch in the comics with
similar powers to wonder she rolled into
their base at the end like wonder rolls
to the illuminati headquarters but
before we could see the outcome
wolverine escaped this also ties to
house of m which featured wonder
creating a fake reality in which he
could be with the kids once more who had
been taken away years before by mephisto
this comic also culminated with strange
going to wonder to try and convince her
to destroy the illusion and she brought
it crashing down on herself which could
hint to what's next for the character
especially she signed a seven-year deal
now the illuminati here are made up of
professor x captain carter the guy from
the slots like advert black belt from
the inhumans mordo mr boombastic tell me
fantastic and lastly tom cruise psych
all those people who said i was wrong
about this being maria rambo l tom
cruise iron man l you are quite nice and
i appreciate that but you're gonna have
to take this l the 8k version of this
trailer gives us a much better look at
this armor-clad illuminati member this
to me looks very much like jonathan
majors
hey paul how's it going it was maria
rambo l you son of a [ __ ]
hey didn't you say al pacino was going
to be in one division
now we don't really learn the ins and
outs of their backstory but we do get
the x-men cartoon theme playing at one
point which leads me to believe this is
the same professor x from the show he
not only has his yellow floating chair
but also his green suit and we know from
the disney plus day event that marvel
are dropping an x-men 97 cartoon at some
point however he could just be a variant
of the show and i think this is
definitely the case with captain carter
carter is confirmed as being in season
two what if and the one we met in that
show ended up reuniting with steve who'd
been turned into a capsicle she drops
and i can do this all day before being
decapitated
a by her own shield as a black bolt for
the three of you who watch the inhumans
hanson mao returns from that but he's in
a far more comic book accurate costume
the character has the tuning fork on his
head and who knows this could mean that
marvel take another crack at the
characters now maria rambo is someone
whose influence has been felt over the
whole mcu since her death which we
learned about in one division turns out
that after the events of captain marvel
that she ended up becoming a founding
member of sword but she died between the
snap in the blip it's nice that there's
a universe in which she still exists so
that monika can be with her mother but
nope wonder kills her now it's clear
that she took the tesseract test flight
instead of carol danvers and how this
happened could have been explaining
captain marvel we learned that the pair
were both called at the base but that
carol took a shortcut so she got there
first what if this didn't happen and
instead maria got there earlier so she
was the one who ended up riding with
marvel carol didn't have any attachments
on earth so she flew into space with her
skrulls but potentially maria remained
behind because she had a daughter lastly
is john krasinski as reed richards this
one fan edit has to stand up and take a
bow as it pretty much got the internet
demanding this until they all turn on it
last week and said it was too obvious
because hey that's what we do now though
he gets uh oh spaghetti old i think
introducing him this way shows that he's
going to be played by john in another
universe and that will likely get him as
the main one in the mcu john watts was
signed on to direct fantastic four
however last week he stepped away from
the project and with krazynski's
directing chops i think it would be
great to get him behind the camera
there's also peyton reed who directed
the ant-man films and he's been saying
for years that he'd love to get involved
with a fantastic full movie so if
krazynski thinks it's a bit too much to
have on his plate he might end up
staying in the roll and just passing it
over to him now with krazynski also
comes the possibility that sue richards
will be played by his wife emily blunt
it's something else the internet asked
for and hey you get what you deserve now
i'm super hyped for it and i really hope
that they got that rude because
krazynski completely nails the little
time that he has on screen against him
we get one of the coldest lines i've
ever heard in a movie when one asks if
his kids have a mother he says yes and
then she says that's good because
they'll have someone to race them god
damn anyway the fact that he mentions
his kids is keeping in with the comics
when he and sue eventually had them in
the mcu we know that reed doesn't have
his powers yet as the fantastic four
probably would have come out by now and
we would have had mention of the baxter
foundation like what we get here now i
think when we meet reid he will be
younger not yet a father and then we'll
develop things from there would be
awesome to see him eventually come face
to face with wonder who's killed him in
another universe i think that would be
such a cool way to take things now in
the film we learn a lot more about the
strange of their earth who form the
illuminati this ties back to the line
we should tell him the truth which sets
the groundwork for discovering more
about the one on their earth the truth
is that doctor strange ended up creating
an incursion which has a lot of
precedent in the comics this happens
when two different realities collide
with one another and it was a major plot
point in the book secret wars which this
film further sets up birds teased that
during loki secret wars was a run in
which multiple earths all ended up
crashing into one another and this
formed a new planet called battle world
which was overseen by doom multiple
versions of the same characters all
fought for control and come the end of
this conflict marvel streamlined the
entire thing to create a new continuity
that kept some things canon whilst it
discarded the rest this is how miles
morales jump from the ultimate universe
into the 616 one and it's likely that
we'll be getting some form of secret
wars as the next major event he he
remains said at the end of loki that
this would happen and kang is probably
going to be the next big danos level
threat we get in the mcu a phase 4 has
very much been about duplicate
characters from other universes we of
course had several spider-man in our way
home loki was filled with a lot of
loki's and this movie has multiple
doctor strangers wonders and so on don't
get me started on ralph bona but it's
clear that multiverse is now officially
open
this again ties in the secret wars in
which we had multiple versions of the
characters appearing i can definitely
see that being this face's end game and
who knows we might get a big battle
scene where everyone from over the last
20 years of marvel movies comes together
now the incursion wiped out universe and
behind the scenes the illuminati put in
place their plan to correct things they
killed thanos to fix it and also had
black bulk killer strange however they
told the light of the public to cover
this up and said that their strange died
fighting thanos whereas the one in the
mcu of course handed over the time stone
we learned that he'd been using the dark
hole to dreamwalk and even after they
told him not to he kept doing it this
corrupted him because the spell came
from the book and it created the
incursion we learned that if you stay in
a universe for too long that it leaves a
footprint which causes universes to
bleed together and this sets up the
post-credits scene that we'll talk about
in just a bit now for years we've been
asking how about the fantastic four and
x-men will be brought into the mcu i
think that inclusion here is gonna be a
bit divisive they go just as quickly as
they show up and yeah let me know in the
comments below if you liked how they
were included or if you feel a bit down
about it now back in the main universe
the darkhold is destroyed and this
wonder has to take things into her own
hands wanda is desperate to find another
dark oldest book and wong tells her
about wondergoal mountain which in the
comics was where it was created this was
by cathon centuries ago and the pair
travel air namely the castle darkhold
there are giant beasts that act as gods
there and these resemble cathon though
we don't know if he'll turn up
eventually throwing wong over the cliff
one ends up exploring the castle at dark
hold as they look for the book and we
catch engravings of the prophesized
skull at which she also goes to the
illuminati universe in order to grab
america she does this by dreamwalking
much like the illuminati strange did and
it allows her to puppet a version of
herself in that universe she wipes the
illuminati out pretty brutally and it's
a super dark scene professor x chokes up
his dead on-screen death after he
attempts to enter her mind in order to
root out the corruption he almost gets
to her but a creepy version of scholar
which arrives and snaps his neck in the
illuminati chamber strange gold's murder
into fighting him by saying that he was
jealous of this universe is strange and
he snaps one of the cuffs on him before
he escapes along with this universe's
christine palmer strange in america
escape into the basement namely to a
door between universes and he uses the
watch he gave him as a gift in the first
film to open up the door grabbing the
book of his shanty things all come to a
head and wonder manages to capture
america and she pushes strange and
christine into a destroyed universe
there's also an oldsmobile reference
here which is a car that sam raimi has
included in every single film at the
center of this is sinister strange
ustrange ends up fighting and killing we
discover that he tapped in in the
darkhold which caused an incursion and
his universe is now in ruins strange
manages to get back to the 616 mcu
universe by dreamwalking in the
defender's strange body which as we've
mentioned is a no-no he masters dark
demons that resemble the deadites and
then he flies to wondergold mountain one
climbs up and now they're beaten by the
skull at which strange inspires america
which finally gives her the ability to
master her powers together she and
wonder travel through to the illuminati
universe in which wanda has her kids and
the one that here realizes how in pain
she is over losing her children it seems
like vision doesn't exist in this
universe either which was a bit of a
weird one as i kind of wanted to see him
in the film a one point wonder snaps
that billy and tommy and after attacking
her mother they're absolutely terrified
of her realizing that she's being
corrupted and consoled by the variant of
herself she finally turns good and
traveling back with america she makes
one final move wanda destroys the
darkhold fortress with herself inside of
it and it's left ambiguous whether she's
alive or not however we do see a red
glow from it as it collapses and learn
that she destroy the dark hold in every
universe now as mentioned earlier
elizabeth elton has signed a brand new
deal with marvel so expect to see her
back spoilers there now there is of
course the unresolved issue with white
vision and i do think that he will be
the one that pulls her back fully from
the brink this is still out there
somewhere and he's technically still a
person that she fell in love with that
was of course his body but he was
reprogrammed by hayward however this was
overwritten by the hex one in one
division at the end of house of m we
caught scarlet witch with her hood up
keeping her head down and this was
somewhat also referenced when she left
west view i think that she will likely
follow the same path as this and that
will be some time before she pops back
up however she will still be alive wanda
was out of the spotlight for several
years in the comics and they will
probably do the same thing here bringing
her back much in the same way that they
brought steve back in infinity war out
of the shadows also back to that civil
war thing wild house steve protected
bucky from tony and here strange
protects america from wonder but i
digress now strange in the christine
varian also say that goodbyes and what
is quite a heartbreaking scene before
sending her back he tells her he loves
her no matter the universe and she cries
because clearly she feels the same way
however they can't be together and he
sends her back which is very sad however
the movie isn't over and we learn that
america becomes a sorcerer apprentice
the film ends with strange collapsing in
the street as he walks through new york
and a third eye opens on his head
showing that he's corrupt from here we
go to the post-credits scene to find him
once more walking and he's approached by
clear played by none other than
charlie's throne she says that he's
caused an incursion and that they need
to stop it she then cuts open reality to
the dark dimension and his third eye
opens showing he may have mastered the
dark energies now in the comics clear
was the daughter of a prince that
formally ruled over the dark dimension
and his wife umar who was the sister of
dor mamu she was brought up believing
that dom mamu was someone to be
worshipped and it is possible that he's
the one who threatens her universe
there's a theory going around at the
moment that domamu could actually be a
strange variant and you might remember
that tony todd was originally meant to
voice the character in the first movie
however this was changed up to benedict
cumberbatch i think it would be a great
twist if this was also a version of
strange who tapped too heavily into the
dark dimension now in the comics
dormammu ordered her to kill strange but
the pair ended up falling in love which
could in towards what's happening in the
future if they don't want to go with
dormammu they could end up going with
someone like wanda kathon or we could
just get kang teased at the end of loki
he would be someone that would
definitely be the kind of person
threatening realities and this would set
up secret wars perfectly i'd love to see
him slowly teased over several movies
and we of course know that he's going to
be in the upcoming ant-man film there
are multiple versions of him out there
and we know from he who remains that for
every good one there is there is a bad
one too so potentially we'll get several
of them across a vast multiverse in some
overarching movies now will strange give
into the dark energy personally i don't
think so the darkhold is destroyed and
america points out that he's not like
any other versions of the character
there's also the fact that the others
couldn't stop the incursions whereas
here it seems like he's going to or at
least going to try i'd love to hear your
thoughts below and as for my thoughts on
the movie i really really enjoyed it and
though i have minor minor issues with it
it was very well laid out heart pounding
at points and a relentless chase this
felt like the comic book version of the
terminator to me and i think wonder
might be my favorite villain in the mcu
now as she's completely ruthless and
unstoppable the pace is really non-stop
but there are also some issues with that
i do think that there could have been
some breathing room during scenes as it
feels like there's a lot on the cutting
room floor that would have helped to
take the movie from being a 9 up to a
10. spoiler alert that's my score now
elizabeth olsen really knocks out the
park again and wonder is by far one of
the most complex and complicated mcu
characters that we have right now on the
opposite side of this is benedict
cumberbatch who provides a low-key
heartbreaking performance at points as
of now i think the guy is up there with
robert downey jr florence pugh hugh
jackman patrick stewart and the rest
with being absolutely perfect casting
the guy can really carry scenes and he's
one of my favorite marvel characters
right now i love how they also brought
horror elements into this movie and
raymie is adapted integrating this into
the story guy knows what he's doing as a
director and this is by far one of the
best shot marvel movies out there
there's so many creative choices that
they do with the camera and at points it
almost feels like an indie film i just
wish there was more of it i feel had
they may be given a good 20 minutes on
top of what we had then this would be
absolutely outstanding but hey it's
still pretty good overall i had a blast
with the movie and it gets you guessed
it and nine point one out of ten huh got
you sucker obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man noway home on
the 15th of may and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film if
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now see if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of moonlight which will be
linked on screen right now the finale
was really i really had a lot to unpack
so definitely go ahead over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time take care peace